[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique avec une question aujourd'hui
la grève at elle encore un avenir
plus précisément faut-il faire grève
pour obtenir satisfaction la tolérance
des usagers at elle évolué et d'autres
formes de lutte sont elles envisageables
après plusieurs mouvements surprise dans
les transports et avant la grande
journée interprofessionnelle du 5
décembre sur les retraites pour en
débattre avec nous philippe texier
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le secrétaire
régional de la cgt pour la bourgogne
franche comté c'est ça nicolas ros
bonjour vous présidez une association
d'usagers des transports au fil des
réseaux une association dijonnaise
dominique andolfatto bonjour bonjour
universitaire spécialiste des syndicats
vous avez écrit de nombreux ouvrages
dont en 2018 vous nous le rappeliez
chemins de fer les cheminots intentions
qui est particulièrement d'actualité
enfin rémy rebeyrotte bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marche
de saône-et-loire merci d'être avec nous
ce matin alors le sujet récurrent on va
rappeler d'abord que le droit de grève à
valeur constitutionnelle
en france quand même temps en europe la
france a le record du nombre de jours de
grève par salarié est le dernier élément
en date c'est ce mouvement surprise à la
sncf suite à un accident sur un ter avec
une grande désorganisation des
transports au début des vacances de la
toussaint
sauf que ce mouvement n'était pas une
grève mais une application du droit de
retrait donc sans les mécanismes qui
peuvent permettre de prévenir et de
préserver les usages et philippe texier
est ce que comme l'a dit le secrétaire
d'état aux transports c'était une
stratégie délibérée de ce que vous en
savez cette extension du droit de
retrait qui finalement a essaimé
donc je crois que le secrétaire d'état
d'ailleurs comme le pdg sortant se sont
empressés de stigmatiser en fait un
droit vous le qualifiez a droit de
retrait qui permet donc aux salariés aux
cheminots a encore présent de pouvoir se
retirer d'une situation qu'ils jugent
menaçante pour leur intégrité et
évidemment lorsqu'on us mais nous on
pense tout de suite à la sécurité des
voyageurs et donc le droit de retrait
est une possibilité a droit pour les
salariés de se retirer
considérant que qu'il ya danger grave et
imminent est ce que c'est du mauvais
esprit de penser que peut-être ça a été
utilisé par
que aujourd'hui il ya des mécanismes
amortisseurs qui ont été mis en place à
la sncf et qui finalement atténuent
l'effet de la grève
je crois qu'il faut surtout pas nier que
ce événement qui aurait pu être
dramatique se situer dans une séquence
dans l'entreprise où on sort d'une
réforme qui éclatent l'entreprise donc
créé une nouvelle entreprise donc avec
un statut de société anonyme au 1er
janvier
donc qui qui est à deux cela ajouté à
des restructurations permanentes à la
mise en place des ordonnances macron et
qui ont modifié considérablement les
instances de représentation du personnel
en clair elle éloigne les lieux de
discussion des réels problèmes qui sont
posés dans les abonnés sens du travail
et vous l'avez dit des menaces qui
pèsent pour l'ensemble des salariés pas
seulement des cheminots sur les
retraites avec la réforme à venir on va
y venir et de façon de façon globale
nicolas ros au delà de la grève prévue
pour les usagers est prévenu ça vous
semble être indispensable
en tout cas logique après de longs peut
comprendre qu'en cas de problèmes
inhérents à la sécurité on ne soit pas
les lèche les cheminots puissent faire
faire valoir leur leur leur droit de
retrait de mémoire il ya déjà eu un
incident similaire en normandie je crois
avec une rame vide identiques qui est
parti à la dérive sur 19 bornes avec 70
personnes à bord heureusement que le
contrôleur était à bord pour faire c'est
faire ce que ce ce que ce qu'il fallait
là il ya des usagers qui ont été laissés
pendant très longtemps
est ce que le conducteur seul ipad est
pas le sens de ma question l'histoire on
la connaît mais le savez la question
c'est est ce que il est important quand
on est une association d'usagers
on sait qu'à la sncf on a mis en place
des mécanismes amortisseurs ou prévenir
les gens
s'il ya une grève oui s'il ya un
problème de sécurité s'est passé on sait
que sur le sujet il ya discussion sur ce
droit de retrait ou pas dominique
andolfatto des périodes cadres et des
greffes cadré qui des grèves pas cadrée
du tout dans l'histoire des syndicats et
s'alternent wyss interne il faut savoir
qu'à la sncf en fait il ya une nouvelle
réglementation de la grève qui est
intervenu il ya une dizaine d'années et
donc il faut déposer après il faut
demander d'abord dès qu'un problème
quelque part il ya une demande de
concertation avec la direction
voici et trouver une solution au
problème puis après il faut déposer un
préavis enfin on déclenche pas une grève
comme cela sur un coup de tête ce qui
était possible autrefois
maintenant il ya toute une procédure à
suivre et là moi je dirais plutôt que
c'est un mouvement de grève spontané une
grève spontanée qui sortait un petit peu
du du cadre habituel faut savoir que le
droit de retrait c'est quand même assez
encadrée juridiquement même si on peut
les importations juridiques sont larges
je suis pas de dire je me retire voilà
c'est un droit individuel il faut qu'il
ya un danger imminent et en fait il y a
les trains circulent sans contrôleur
depuis plusieurs dans beaucoup de
régions depuis depuis longtemps le
transilien il n'ya pas non plus de
contrôleurs à bord etc desriac des
brigades qui circulent donc il faut
plutôt voir là un le fait que les que
les cheminots sont en colère que la
coupe license est un peu une
cocotte-minute actuellement et voilà
c'est un symptôme de de ce qui se passe
actuellement dans les séries que le
dernier élément c'est ce matin dans le
journal du dimanche le nouveau pdg de la
sncf a annoncé qu'ils se poserait pas la
question juridique de cet usage du droit
de retrait puisque en fait on savait pas
si il allait être contestées ou pas
est-ce que c'est un usage extensif ou
pas il a dit que voilà
ils voulaient apaiser les choses on se
poserait pas la question rémy rebeyrotte
le droit de retrait c'est important
l'information des usagers aussi la
position du politique elle est
particulière parce que d'abord le droit
de grève
il est constitutionnel en france en même
temps les réformes je pense que vous
souhaitez qu'elle avance alors on dit
quoi on dans ces cas là écoutez la
réponse de monsieur taissy est assez
clair c'est à dire que on est sur l'abus
du droit de retrait quand on dit à
partir d'un droit de retrait parce qu'il
ya un contexte général dans l'entreprise
on met en place une grève de cette
ampleur
ça veut dire qu'on est plus fectivement
dans le respect d'un droit qui est celui
du droit de retrait qui est complètement
légitime mais qui est ponctuel quellier
à une situation d'insécurité qualifier
on a hélas par exemple régulièrement
dans les transports en bus on a dans
l'urbain souffre transports urbains des
personnes qui se font agresser
absolument dramatique bon imaginez qu'à
chaque fois le droit de retrait s'exerce
à l'ensemble du réseau routier français
pour les conducteurs de bus
vous imaginez la situation qui serait
celle de notre payer il ya des droits le
droit de grève est un droit
constitutionnel il a des règles dans les
transports effectivement ça a été
rappelé depuis une dizaine d'années qui
permet en fait allé cncf de réorganiser
de manière extrêmement rapide son réseau
et sa manière d'implanter des personnels
pour pouvoir au mieux satisfaire aux
besoins des usagers
la force est de constater qu'il n'y a
pas eu respect des textes alors c'était
notre point de départ est la question
centrale c'est est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
grève c'est efficace en france pour pour
obtenir alors pour nous empêcher
certaines évolutions quand on est on les
considère comme nuisible canton des
syndicats ou pour obtenir quelque chose
n'était que c est ce qu une grève
aujourd'hui c'est efficace en france où
est ce qu'il faut faire plus mathieu je
voudrais répondre à monsieur le député
je crois qu'ils qui kiffent kirop qui
rejoint les propos du pdg sortant
dans sa réponse il fait porter la
responsabilité
en fait d'une grève qui dirait pas son
nom aux cheminots qui ont versé leur
douar de rentrée je précise quand même
que les problèmes qui en ce moment sur
le réseau ne sont pas seulement du fait
que des cheminots avec les frères de
rentrée c'est aussi des cheminots qui
ont décidé dans des établissements
et notamment les établissements qui sont
chargés de la maintenance du tgv cg
autres mouvements selleck naissance hla
entretenir une confusion et dire en fait
que ce sont l'ensemble des cheminots qui
exercent leur droit d'entrée en ce
moment et qui cause des problèmes de
gêne aux usagers
c'est faux on parlait du départ des
vacances effectivement il ya deuxième
mouvement voilà c'est ça pas sûr que le
média deuxième mouvement le deuxième
mouvement celui des technicentres il est
emblématique aussi en ce moment parce
que c'était une discussion sur les
technicentres plutôt local avec un texte
retiré et une grève qui ce qui se
produit quand même alors que le texte
était retirée donc qu'est ce qu'on
cherche dans ce cas là philippe texier
que cherchent les gens des technicentres
en faisant grève alors que le texte qui
contestaient été retiré par exemple
aujourd'hui les d'abord le mouvement il
est parti depuis ces établissements sur
des problèmes de remise en cause d'un
accord qui existait dans l'entreprise
d'une décision unilatérale des chefs
d'établissement les personnels sont déjà
sous pression du fait faut savoir que
ces ateliers sont chargés donc d'assurer
la préparation des tgv pour 7 buts en
bonne situation de sécurité pour le
transport de la population appartement
remet en cause un accord qui dégradent
les conditions de travail c'est à dire
les délais de prévenance lé régime
d'astreinte leurs relations du travail
les personnels se sont mis en
mobilisation donc maintenant est ce que
ça marche
alors j'essaie d'arriver à ma question
oui il ya eu des discussions qui se sont
engagées ont permis que la direction
recul sur un certain nombre de
dispositions et aujourd'hui les
personnels demandent qu'une partie des
jours de grève soient présents alors
pourquoi pas ce qu'ils considèrent que
de jour en jour la direction aurait pu
négocier plutôt et considère qu'à partir
du moment où on aurait pu négocier plus
tôt il considère que la grève est allé
était de la responsabilité de
l'employeur et non pas de leurs
responsabilités
je rappelle qu'ici ce sont mis en grève
c'est pouvoir préparer des trains de
bonnes conditions de transports pour les
usagers
en tout cas celle c'est l'argumentaire
des syndicats qui donc direction donc je
vous que je vous club pour la grève donc
pour les voiliers la grève
elle a eu son utilité et demeure même si
on pourra discuter de des formes qui
sait
l'effort voulu réagir pour être précis
six se sont mis en grève c'est parce que
la direction serré de façon unilatérale
avait retiré et 16 jours de congés que
ses salariés avaient donc dans un cas
comme celui-là c'est à dire un grand
établissement public ça marche
la grève pour l'instant le mouvement
n'est pas n'est pas complètement achevé
il se poursuit on ne sait pas c'est de
nouveau une grève spontanée
c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau
convoi la sncf on ne respecte pas non
plus le cadre légal de la grèce c'est
une grève qui a été déclenchée en dehors
des syndicats également
donc c'est un autre aspect des choses
même s'il ya des questions qu'on voulait
se poser
voilà donc il ya une interrogation
également sûr on sait qui est un pouvoir
syndical fo à la sncf
et curieusement et on voit se développer
ses nerfs semaines des mouvements en
dehors des syndicats donc ça interroge
sur le rôle des syndicats sur les aides
sociales ses entreprises on sent qu'il
ya un mécontentement qui existe à la
base je parlais d'une pcf cocotte-minute
ont failli à des tensions et on voit que
d'une certaine manière pour dire que la
sncf est en train de vivre un peu ce
tronçon vous demandez gilet jaune
c'est quelque chose des mouvements
sociaux se développent en dehors des
corps intermédiaires habituels ce qui
est relativement inquiétant sur la
gestion des entreprises avec des
graisses des mouvements de grève qui
était cadré je parlais des systèmes
amortisseurs tout à l'heure pour les
usagers qui du coup sont qui du coup
sont d'autres sont débordés nicolas ros
on parlait beaucoup de l'opinion parce
que quand il ya un mouvement comme ça un
mouvement surprise la question c'est ce
qu'on appelle la bataille de l'opinion
quand les usagers que vous représentez
particulier sur les transports urbains
en côte d'or c'est quoi leur attitude en
général
alors je sais que vous êtes adhérent de
la fnh note que la fnaut t elle une
position très très dur là dessus en
parlant souvent de prise d'otages c'est
quoi la réaction des gens en général les
gens aient encore une grève ils sont pas
contents après c'est sûr que si on
n'explique pas ce qui se passe parce que
c'est souvent ce qui se passe je veux
dire on va dire aux gens c'est une
journée mais comment dire noir c'est
jojo c'est une journée pardon de galère
c'est une prise d'otages et c'est sans
jamais finalement parler vraiment de ce
qui se passe donc les gens ne peuvent
être que contre ça c'est normal nous en
tant qu'association du geste d'usagé
pardon ce qui nous intéresse un peu plus
c'est comment
on peut faire pour eux je vais dire
éviter la grève c'est là pour nous faire
re regardez simplement ce qui se passe
au japon
il met un brassard et tout de suite on
ouvre une négociation c'est pas ce qui
se passe en france on va attendre 48
heures on laisse pourrir le truc qu'on
reçoit un syndicat mais pas l'autre il a
pas représentatifs de la barre f il ya
c'est pas du tout fait mais ça nous met
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que ça nous amène effectivement à
ceux dont on voulait parler c est ce que
il ya une alternative à ça il n'y a que
des pratiques mais ce qu'il ya une
alternative à sa famille rebeyrotte
on parle tout le temps du modèle
allemand où on négocie tout le temps ils
ont fait jamais grève dans votre nouveau
monde de la république en marche on sait
ça le monde idéal selon m soyons précis
une grève c'est jade et dire
l'aboutissement d'un processus
normalement de dialogue de discussions
dans l'entreprise par exemple qui n'a
pas abouti et à un moment donné par la
grève ya un arbitrage c'est à dire que
l'entreprise hyper sur ses recettes
pendant la grève et les salariés y
perdent sur leur salaire
et c'est un arbitrage dans le temps avec
une tension qui doit d'ailleurs en
général il sait bien aboutir à une
reprise de discussions c'est ça j'allais
dire une grève
or on est dans une forme de dévoiement
je parlais tout à l'heure de la question
du droit de retrait mais quand on voit
par exemple les grèves annoncées le 5
décembre
c'est aussi ce qui m' avant même avant
même qu'il y ait une négociation une
discussion puisqu'elle a commencé la
semaine dernière entre le secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports
les syndicats dont certaines viennent à
la table d'autres non et j'allais dire
de l'ensemble de ceux qui sont concernés
par l'évolution notamment jean paul
delevoye et ceux qui sont concernés par
l'évolution des retraites
là je dis qu on est en dehors de la
logique tout simplement de la grève
c'est à dire que il faut d'abord
discuter travailler ensemble le jean
paul delevoye va rencontrer avec les
différents ministres les quarante deux
régimes spéciaux pour regarder comment
on peut faire
on s'aperçoit qu'à vente les discussions
des commencé avant on annonce déjà un
jour de grève
certains disent même des grèves
reconductibles c'est là on dévoie si
vous voulez le droit de grève
de la même manière sur le dépôt dont on
parlait tout à l'heure à partir du
moment où il n'y a plus le motif à la
grève puisque j'allais dire la direction
a reculé à tort ou à raison je ne
connais pas suffisamment le fond du
dossier pour pouvoir j'allais dire jugé
moto cas ce qui est sûr ce qui faisait
grève un moment donné a disparu de la
discussion
dès lors le dialogue doit pouvoir
reprendre et sa dialogue là que l'on
appelle c'est à dire il y a des règles
si vous voulez et des règles qui doivent
permettre aux mécanismes de discussion
de pouvoir toujours aller jusqu'au bout
et j'invite l'ensemble du monde syndical
à être au contraire autour de la table
alors fait des petits excès dévoiement
écoutez je suis un peu surpris quand
même que que vous puissiez qualifié la
journée d'action qui se dessine devant
nous le 5 décembre journée d'action qui
est dans un cadre unitaire important
avec des organisations de jeunesse qui
sont venus rejoindre les syndicats
salariés alors qu' évidemment en premier
lieu il ya les inquiétudes vous avez dit
pardon je vous coupe vous avez dix
journées d'action alors une journée
d'action c'est dans la tradition
française c'est quoi ça sert à montrer
sa force a montré journée d'action c'est
pas la même chose que débrayer pour dire
voilà les actions c'est une
confédération et qui est l'oncle à
plusieurs confédérations et des
ordinations en acheter un autre jeunesse
qui décident ensemble de se mobiliser et
d'appeler les salariés a donc décidé de
la graine à participer aux différentes
différents rassemblements qui pourraient
avoir lieu dans les localités
ça veut dire que ce sont des
confédérations qui ont la légitimité de
d'avoir un champ d'activité sur
plusieurs générations sur plusieurs
professions et donc c'est un événement
en soi mais que celui ci réponde je vous
fais répondre à une erreur devient un
gouvernement qui depuis plusieurs mois a
décidé de merde à l'ordre du jour une
nouvelle réforme sur les retraites dans
laquelle il annonce vouloir allonger la
durée donc de travail
et en mettant en creux la possibilité de
changer du système avec un système par
points
ces discussions là nous les avons eus
système par répartition mais parfois
c'est à dire que on nous on arrive dans
des rites les changes a déjà eu lieu et
que donc vous pouvez faire grève
maintenant que la négociation continue
mais on voit bien que les objectifs que
le gouvernement s'est assigné continue
détenus est ce que c'est encore est ce
que c'est encore compréhensible pour
l'opinion publique pardon de vous couper
mais pour l'opinion publique de dire on
fait une journée d'action c'est à dire
ce jour-là n'y aura pas de médecin si
vous êtes parisien je mets mais il n'y a
pas de danger immédiat pour pour notre
voie là où est ce que je veux dire ce
que moi ce que je vois c'est aussi ce
que disent les français et pas que les
salariés dans les sondages on voit bien
que la majorité des français n'espère
pas grand chose de cette réforme
en termes d'évolution positive pour eux
ils ont beaucoup de craintes et donc je
pense que cette crainte là et elle doit
pouvoir s'exprimer et donner l'occasion
de se mobiliser je vous coupe quand même
parce que il ya un sondage doxa pour
france info sur le mouvement du 5 6
français sur 10 estiment que mouvement
de grève à la sncf prévu le 5 est
injustifiée et soit 77% souhaite
l'instauration d'un service minimum on
n'est quand même pas tellement dans
l'adhésion
on parle d'une réforme des retraites qui
concerne l'ensemble des salariés et vous
faites allusion à un sondage qui parle
de l'action c'est dans les transports
dans les transports et transport vous
avez raison oui donc vous avez raison ce
qu'il dominique andolfatto voulait jouer
je coupe un peu pour que le monde puisse
parler quand même dominique andolfatto
voulez vous lire bondir aussi là dessus
sur ce que disait un ami robert
normalement on négocie puis après on
fait grève oui mais enfin envisagé ici
c'est une espèce de grève
d'avertissement fait on fait monter la
température passe quand les points de
vue sont pas d'accord et c'est donc on
essaye de faire monter là la mayonnaise
en quelque sorte progressivement ce que
je suis ce que je voulais dire c'est pas
une journée d'action s'est bien et
d'ailleurs peut-être que le secrétaire
général de la cgt ici pression n'est pas
le plus indiqué pour parler de ce
mouvement parce qu'en fait il a pire il
a pris train en marche puisque en fait
ce moment à l'origine cc l'unsa est et
sud rail qui ont voulu ce mouvement est
la ratp est en fait la cgt s'est senti
obligé dessus dans un deuxième temps
parce qu'elle était en quelque sorte
doublée et et sur sa gauche et et sur sa
droite
pas par deux autres organisations de la
ratp et c'était donc pas la sncf dans un
premier temps et pour ses deux autres
syndicats c'est bien une grève qui se
veut par dessus le marché reconductible
alors on peut s'interroger sur
légitimiser de grève est ce qu'elle est
légitime ou pas le fêter c'est que cette
cette réforme elle est plus ou moins
anxiogène me semble-t-il parce qu'elle
dure depuis un certain temps les les
français ne savent pas exactement ce qui
va se passer on nous dit que le système
de retraite par points ce sera un
système qui sera plus équitable mais
manifestement les niveaux de pension
tels qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui ne
sont pas garanties donc il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes de deux amants un mot sur
un mot sur notre fantasme du modèle
allemand
on négocie beaucoup on fait grève on ne
fait jamais grève c'est vrai ou c'est du
fantasme français
cc c'est quand même assez largement du
fantasme il ya beaucoup de grèves en
allemagne il ya une grève aux états unis
actuellement chez general motors qui a
duré 50 jours qui a fait vraiment
d'activités sociales états unis de tout
ce semestre qui vient de se passer et
les salariés viennent d'obtenir une
prime de plus de 10000 euros par du
petit mille dollars par parents et des
précaires un peu plus de 4000 donc la
grève donc la grève c'est une danse
kallas mais c'est un exact ça un avenir
maintenant que les très longs des
questions qu'on pose la question qu'on
pose est il nous reste un petit peu de
temps encore la question c'est qu'on
voulait poser c'est est ce qu'il ya
d'autres formes possibles d'actions pour
obtenir satisfaction dans le champ
social
alors on a parlé par exemple des grèves
perlées qui faisait que 50 minutes et
pas une heure des choses comme ça il ya
aussi aujourd'hui quelque chose qui se
développe de façon fort par rapport à
dire la codification des grèves tous les
mouvements tourner une forme de
désobéissance civique c'est à dire en
fait on respecte plus les règles
philippe taxi vous votre préoccupation
c'est quand même que les syndicats
réussissent à tenir ça en fait
finalement et à respecter les règles
parce que sinon il peut y avoir
vous avez dit tout à l'heure une forme
de mouvement des gilets jaunes terme
dans les syndicats
je crois qu'il faut pas être prétentieux
et en tout cas celui aujourd'hui qui dit
qui serrait de se mettre en position de
vouloir tout tenir
non je crois que le mouvement social il
se transforme entre ce qu'on a pu
connaître au moins jusqu au mieux les
années 90 cirque un mouvement syndical
qui était à la fois soit contrepoids ou
soit en position de chercher des
débouchés politiques on voit qu'avec les
mouvements altermondialistes jusqu'aux
années 2000
évidemment aujourd'hui les questions de
l'environnement qui sont présentes en
termes d'attentes notamment des jeunes
générations mais pas seulement si aussi
les petites entreprises qui sont les
entreprises dont on n'a pas parlé parce
que finalement on parle là c'est les
grands groupes et en fait des dons des
salariés qui ont du mal à exercer leur
droit de grève et donc des politiques
d'austérité qui se renforce
qui est qui touche là au quotidien les
salariés les plus fragilisés les moins
formés les retraités qui ont des faibles
pensions ont été aussi un élément qui
ont peut-être permis a conduit à ce que
ce mouvement prenne la forme du
mouvement d'idées gilet jaune
donc il ya aussi d'autres mouvements qui
ce qui existe à l'hôpital dans la santé
avec des pâtes riz praticiens qui décide
de ne pas remplir qui font grève de la
codification fier qu'il décide de ne pas
remplir le public
les formulaires pour look la t2a qui
permet donc à l'assurance maladie donc
d'alimenter les caisses de l'hôpital
donc je pense qu'il ya une recherche
chez les ch et les salariés et je pense
qu'il faut faire faut regarder cette
intelligence alors est-ce qu'elle va
supplanter la grève
moi je ne crois pas tous tous ceux faut
regarder ça à l'intérieur du mouvement
qui qui qui est dans une dynamique pour
sortir de politiques d'austérité et je
pense que dans ce mouvement là le
syndicalisme ben est interpellé
mais il est interpellé pourrait y
compris lui pour être plus efficace pour
être plus près des salariés
donc je crois que la grève elle n'est
pas elle va pas s'arrêter avec des
nouvelles formes d'action je pense que
on risquerait d'être encore je pense
encore l'otan dans cette configuration
c'est une de nos questions du jour
nicolas ros on parlait beaucoup
effectivement vous représenter les
usagers du ressenti que les gens peuvent
avoir et par rapport à des mouvements
qui peuvent être beaucoup plus
surprenant beaucoup plus rapides alors
effectivement ça tourne beaucoup autour
du droit de retrait dans les transports
urbains ça c'est quelque chose qui
arrive souvent
c'est arrivé à dijon avec des chauffeurs
qui décide d'arrêter de conduire les
trams quand il prenait des cailloux ont
pris ce y compris en ce moment le
tramway s'arrête un je crois la station
bout et ça va pas jusqu'au bout va pas
juste les soirs au moindre caillou sais
pas voilà donc on parlait de droit de
retrait s'il existe pas sûr pas sur l'un
l'ensemble du réseau mais
la hausse est dangereux il vous semble
que les usagers devraient aussi être un
peu associés ou pas à ça la fnaut tu
auquel vous appartenez s'est créé aussi
pour ça pour exister dans les
discussions qui peut y avoir sur les sur
les transports et complice ou des
transports régionaux on parle des gars
on parle des distributeurs de billets on
parle de tout ça donc est-ce que les
vous pensez que les usagers doivent être
présentés oui oui oui c'est une évidence
et je pense que la fnte aujourd'hui un
travail à faire pour revenir vers les
gens parce que ya pas beaucoup de gens
qui skie ce qu'ils savent ce que c'est
la fnaut ce à quoi elle sert je veux
parler d'autres modes de de grève il ya
une chose qu'on aimerait dont on rêve
c'est la grève du zèle des contrôleurs
on aimerait en fait des trains gratuits
alors c'est illégal de ce que c'est et
les cheminots pour le coup je me pose un
peu faim ne semble pas trop trop pousser
vers ça mais si si le les si le service
était maintenue et que les trains
étaient gratuits je vous assure il
aurait 95 15 % des usagers qui
soutiendrait le plat cette grève est la
la la direction de l'entreprise serait
fortement pénalisées dans notre bataille
de l'opinion c'était un élément qu'on
avait peur qu'on n'avait pas évoqué rémy
rebeyrotte cette idée les syndicats y
sont nécessaires pour empêcher que
finalement les grèves devienne
incontrôlable en réalité moi je suis
assez favorable ça a été le cas pour la
réforme pénicaud pour celles d'ailleurs
de la sncf aussi en partie à des
discussions et des négociations qui sont
tenues dans le temps et je crois que
c'est la meilleure garantie pour les
syndicats en termes de capacité pour eux
à incarner justement ce face à face
vis-à-vis du gouvernement vis-à-vis de
l'entreprise je suis y compris
d'ailleurs sur la réforme des retraites
attention à ne pas anticiper la
concertation et du rhône qui doit
vraiment est-ce que ce qui était dit
tout à l'heure les peurs ou les craintes
a vraiment pouvoir discuter du fond
entre les représentants du personnel
entre les représentants syndicaux avec
ceux qui mènent la réforme est de fixer
un moment le délai pour que l'on puisse
avancer
je crois que le pire
c'est tout ce qui reste justement sans
règles on en parle on élabore finalement
vous rêvez tous évoqués il nous reste
peu de temps dominique andolfatto la
grève elle a un avenir ou pas il faut
savoir que les français en fait on font
très peu grève
un français en moyenne d'après si on dit
les statistiques fait grève un jour tous
les vingt ans en moyenne ce qui est ce
qui est finalement très peu c'est à dire
que dans une carrière moyenne un salarié
va faire rire en moyenne deux jours dans
toute sa carrière ce qui est très peu
par contre il ya certaines professions
certaines catégories qui recourent
beaucoup à la grève notamment les
cheminots les cheminots les statistiques
nous disent qu'ils font 100 fois plus
grève en moyenne que le salarié moyen ce
qui est considérable et on peut
s'interroger sur le résultat obtenu
ces graines on sait que le statut a été
adoptée l'année passée et ce qu'on voit
se développer actuellement ses essais
des grèves je le disais un peu en dehors
des des syndiqués a donc ça interroge un
petit peu sûres et la régulation sociale
la sncf et et le rôle des syndicats aux
roues merci à tous les quatre c'est la
fin de notre émission merci à tous les
quatre d'être venu sur notre plateau
la semaine prochaine on se penchera sur
l'hôpital et la réforme de la santé
dans l'immédiat rester avec nous sur
france 3 pour les informations de la mi
journée puis la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique
merci bon dimanche au revoir
[Musique]